hey David do you consider yourself
Hispanic what about Latino what about an
immigrant speaking of identity politics
a question about what is my identity
this is like a really really long thing
obviously I'm an immigrant in the sense
that I was born in Argentina and I
emigrated to the United States there's
this really funny story that I'm
reminded of when I was in middle school
there was an assembly where they
announced we are going to be giving
awards my earpiece fell out here we were
going to be giving awards for
achievement by Latino students and all
of a sudden they say David Pakman please
and I was genuinely confused and I went
home and said to my parents are we lit
in Spanish of course the language I grew
up and still speak at home are we Latino
are we Hispanic what's the difference so
here's my take on on this question not
that my identity matters but because it
is the question that was asked I was
born in Argentina and I grew up speaking
Spanish so I am clearly of what I call
Hispanic culture or Argentinean culture
that's the culture I was raised in now
oftentimes there are racial or ethnic
questions tied up in these questions I
was born to a Jewish family who moved to
Argentina from Eastern Europe much like
many Jews moved to the United States
before World War two so my ethnicity is
Ashkenazi Jewish in the United States
aside from some white nationalists I
guess typically Ashkenazi Jews are
considered is considered white when it
comes to their race or ethnicity had I
been born in the United States I would
clearly be considered white by the
definitions of the census to the extent
that Jews are considered white so let's
maybe dig in a little more to the like
Hispanic Latino thing one version of
Hispanic versus Latino is that Hispanic
is everyone from spanish-speaking
countries in South and Latin America and
that includes Spain and Europe as well
while Latino is all countries that are
physically in South and Central America
but not Spain which is in Europe and
it's more complex because you have
places like Haiti and Martinique and st.
Martin there they're sort of not Latino
they're not really Hispanic by any of
these definitions and
so it starts to get a little bit
complicated and then Brazil as a
Portuguese speaking South American
country also sometimes it's complex I
actually think that that's basically a
distraction for us I'm definitely a
Hispanic immigrant to the US from Latin
America
I am definitely ethnically Jewish and I
pass as white in the United States
because I'm Natalia nuff age so that I
don't have an accent
other than some specific words that slip
out every once in a while I tend not to
use the term Latino because it does feel
a little bit tainted in the context of
the immigration debate but at the same
time I feel like Hispanic is very
imprecise because you might be talking
about a Guatemalan immigrant or a family
of multi-generational wealth in Spain
and politically it's not just class in
terms of money
politically those are very very
different things and the idea that
Hispanic and Kumbha so it encompasses
all of it okay it just seems
extraordinarily broad and imprecise
anyway people have often seen me sort of
mess with my own identity when guests
try to use my perceived identity against
me in some way and I sometimes have
joked with my girlfriend I'm not white
but the truth is I'm Hispanic by culture
I met Nick Jewish which is white in the
United States for all intents and
purposes so I would say yes I am
Hispanic I think I I think I I guess I
am Latino if I have to use that for a
that term although I try not to use it
because I feel like it is stigmatized in
the immigration debate and I am
definitely an immigrant my passport will
confirm that we've got a great bonus
show planned for you today please become
a member at david pakman.com slash
membership and also I am now streaming
on Twitch behind the scenes more casual
streams with a lot of audience
participation follow me on twitch at
twitch.tv slash David Pakman and please
if you have Amazon Prime for free you
can subscribe to my channel with twitch
Prime it costs you nothing but it's a
paid subscription for us okay just
Google how to subscribe to twitch Prime
and it'll take you should be like a
minute and that is a really really great
thing for
speak to you on the bonus show in just a
couple of minutes